rocket fire hit the jail shortly after
lights out on Sunday night over a
hundred prisoners escaped in the ensuing
chaos city officials say some are
extremely dangerous and it's difficult
to gauge the threat they may pose
remains of grad missile were found in
the prison grounds it's a weapon that
analysts say is used by both sides in
the current conflict rebel fighters have
dug in in the city and a government
assault is likely to result in civilian
casualties Kiev is telling people to get
out now wait that was she resort amateur
done with me we are once again calling
on civilians to urgently leave Donetsk
and Luhansk if possible ding chisora we
shoot them because an operation will be
held to liberate those cities and kill
the terrorists deletion yet to release
too many residents remaining in Donetsk
have taken refuge in basements some say
fleeing is not an option I can't go
anywhere you need to have money to go
somewhere the rich people have already
left alongside the threat to their
safety people are also facing a shortage
of food water and fuel